how much of being a professional writer
is understanding the importance of craft
versus the business of writing this is
one of the common and most important
distinctions that is often made when
we're talking about writing
professionally but there is a basic
misunderstanding
that's going on there that is putting
them these two things in opposition of
each other and in fact way I look the
way I like to look at it is that
understanding the craft of writing a big
part of that is dealing with it in a
businesslike way now what most writers
think about the business of story
whether it be in film or television
they're thinking in terms of writing a
story writing an idea that can sell a
big mistake nobody can predict what will
sell nobody can predict what is
commercial and if you try to do that you
will always fail and you'll you know
have constant frustration for the rest
of your life through money the rest of
your writing life instead what I try to
purge writers to do is to approach their
craft in a businesslike way which means
first of all learn the craft learn the
craft don't think it's all about who I
know know it's all about is it on the
page did you write a great script but
then treating your craft in a
businesslike way also has to do with do
I can I create this script in a
particular genre that the entertainment
business is going to buy there are
certain genres not story ideas that are
commercial there are certain genres that
are more commercial than others there
are certain genres for example that we
get in television that we get a lot of
for example dr. dramas legal dramas
detective stories so in treating your
craft in a businesslike way it means how
do I take the steps that I need to take
to have a career as a writer to be paid
as a writer professionally over many
years in fact in my TV class the entire
TV class is structured according to the
steps that the writer has to go through
to make a career out of writing for
television and that includes things like
how do you write your spec script which
show do you choose to write your spec
script for what must be in that spec
script what are the beats of the genre
that you're gonna have to hit for that
spec script to work and so on that's you
you can see that the in all of those
things craft and being businesslike are
the same and the big problem that I
always have with writers who have this
tremendous desire to write
professionally is they think in the old
romantic tradition of it's all about
getting that inspiration from above and
somehow just creating this perfectly
written or well-structured well-written
script and that has nothing to do with
how a great script is written or be how
a great script is sold so that's why I
put so much emphasis in my classes on
taking a businesslike approach to your
craft if you want to write
professionally and I always love this
metaphor you know I would love to be the
starting point guard for the Lakers
right but I can't walk onto the court
and say hey you know Kobe's injured now
so I really like to play just because
you really want to do it doesn't mean
you get to do it those players have
years of training and they've approached
their sport as a craft where they learn
all the skills they practice them at
an item and now they're ready to perform
on the at the professional level
storytelling for film and television is
at least as competitive as professional
sports so you have to have that same
approach in order to succeed
you